welcome to this video playing Grand
Master yet but Eric LeBron and he's not
playing the Kings gambit once in a while
he does that and it usually leads to
really crazy games but now we just have
a typical classical rui i play my odd
trusted yeah 95 the chicken it's playing
with d3 though and black has got more
than one good set up against that this
is one of them which doesn't mean I like
is better or anything but black has got
some some ways to get a decent position
this is one way the idea is to UM after
some preparation even played d5 if
possible quite often y term will play a
delayed yeah exactly delayed d 32 d for
this however it's normally answered by
opening up the center completely and
getting getting quite a quite good piece
play Bishop f6 is answered by night to
h5 which is a bit a bit bit annoying
okay my threatening something night
before this probably just nonsense maybe
just a thread a strengthening move
if he takes Tafoya I can play with
Bishop f6 I thought but in fact yeah i
can i can actually I cannot take the six
Bishop f6 Queen f6 quindi six books e 2
and 0 maybe it can we can't take b6 on f
2 is covered I thought F to detect I'm
talking about Bishop of six Queen a sex
queen d6 whoopsie two queen bees are
okay yeah he didn't play it and probably
with with good reason so what now arrow
key to is the good news the good both he
wants to play look to detune and this
would be would be helpful so at least
it's a good strategic health
maybe maybe this one trying to tickle
him maybe Bishop 2g Bishop takes 3 3's
an idea and I can't play maybe a queen
move Queen to f6 for example I must I
must be cautious about the night yeah be
success hanging and the night is also a
bit of a problem peace it's not yeah
that's limited by the spawn I cannot go
to see 42 a 40 to d5 it covers d5 but
what what is this actually doing okay if
I go green f six thousand I Drive
Queen f6 Queen f6 night h5
ok but i can't play can do that actually
he takes b6 i take a one queen ayb
should be three wow I forgot about
Bishop e3 about but I have Queen to quit
to somewhere we're covered queen e five
probably Quinn a 1 i've got Queen d2
group is 325 Wow nah it looks at it
looks shaky it looks really shaky okay
it's an exchange of if it doesn't find
something something great quickly then
it's an exchange for not for not much
weight here and then whatever for yeah
well force also been weakening
23 I thought the truck nay nay bishop
deform I'm a g3 hangs Wow
huh if five
I don't know I feel like need to I need
to open this position for the rooks
somewhere
I didn't see that at all wow you finally
can take
Wow with the big point I don't see it
other is none here yeah it's still it's
still slightly tricky not objectively
bird in a practical game I need to be
need to be cautious and to get rid of
this bishop may be here should see five
getting into this can we cannot spend
all day on this and of course I will it
that with him but I can take him
and only hope that Queen f6 is not
winning now could be I can take it to
it's
this is not winning it's hard to believe
check
King f to Bishop g3
I grew gave one look at one of course ah
so silly yeah then this is not working
at all Queenie r6 just just a big Bluff
but ok your head you never know you
never know so can you have to I fruk
everyone know this seems to be made but
I didn't see it I saw that one it's
enough yeah he someone lost the thread
down from a from an interesting position
this is not not working at all but here
I'm not sure I'm really not sure this
position looks like white might have
something yeah the compass on on just
0.5 0.5 yeah interesting game really
interesting here somewhere around here
it gets its good acne her wide here yeah
here after this it's a pretty pretty big
edge already ok if we cannot catch this
Bishop it's it's just nonsense difficult
game yeah thanks for watching